la médaille c'est pas mal de nara moi
c'est à moi d'aller les chercher
c'est ça qu'il faut se répéteront toute
la journée je veux quelque chose tu y
vas
hamon megan et où les joies
moi je suis quelqu'un j'ai parole
publique de par mon statut d' parce que
j'ai fait par le passé j'ai pas loin
si on va nous placer la venue de
l'allemagne ma maman et mon mahb a
promis lannion maison bien fort
soufflera du sud
alors j'étais parano et je joue
je n'ai pas pas mon gars et d'or c'est
pas un gars tout ce qu'il gagnera ou
tout ce qu'il aura qui il croit qu'il
est méritée
je veux quelqu'un qui soit ambitieux qui
radient ses rêves comme j'ai appris à
réaliser
mecs qui vont se battre pour pouvoir me
prendre s'ils vont me rentrait pas
je perde mon épaule je vois donc je
préfère rester sur 7 je sais que mon
corps va pouvoir bien réagir à cette
opération
moi je suis obligé d'aller vite et bien
duke la terreur laisse moi tranquille
j'ai pris ma décision
j'écoute mon massage
voilà
la fierté
j'écoute ma maison
m